[Musique]
c'est bien gentil avant de nous faire
des crêpes
vous nous en avait déjà fait ah oui oh
mais vous savez on nous en demande
on m'a demandé alors je vais simplement
varier la façon de les préparer
mais nous allons toujours retomber tout
de même sur des normes de base c'est à
dire sur la façon de faire les crèmes 14
ans a précisé qu' il ya tous les jours
des spectacles vont les voir si
catherine aime passer le beurre on nous
demande des recettes que nous avons déjà
donné alors qu'en donnant d'autres
recettes on reparle en voyage aux îles
six gélules et quibou créances et les
ouïes assez peu dans celui qui vous je
vais mettre un tout petit peu de beurre
également à fondre charaf n'a pas
falloir que sa cuisse non non non oui je
leur tire d'ailleurs du feu je coupe ce
beurre en petits morceaux tout
simplement pour qu'ils font à
l'intérieur du lait que voici est
pratiquement vous allez sur du jeu la
survie
bon il à vous la gemmi la farine je ne
vais pas pesé et vous expliquer que ce
n'est pas nécessaire vous voyez à peu
près ce qu'il vous faut
vous mettez cette farine en pluie à
l'intérieur du puits j'ai mis une grande
cuillère d'huile et dans cette huile g
casser des oeufs
je n'ai cassé quatre pour le mangement
casser un cinquième il faut travailler
vous expliquer pourquoi il n'est pas
nécessaire de peser il faut de toute
façon mettre suffisamment d'offres pour
qu'ils absorbent la totalité de
l'appareil
alors ceci étant des principes absolus
dans l'occurrence enfin en ce qui
concerne cette lettre m'a dit c'est
selon la quantité de crêpes qu'on veut
faire mais il n'y a pas une proportion
entre 5 e 250 g de farine on parce que
il ya les farines qui absorbent plus ou
moins 9
il ya des grosseurs d'heure très
différentes vous pouvez avoir des yeux
qui sombre et par exemple presque deux
fois plus importants les uns que les
autres puisque les moyens on peut encore
ajouter neuf puisque là nous voyons
vous en fait à peu près pour faire
combien de crêpes la fosse 6 personnes
environ de 6 à 8 personnes
oui j'ai mis six heures déjà autrement
dit on pourrait presque considérer que
neuf pas personnes suffirait
on peut dire aussi qu'il y avait 250 g
de farine à peu près voyez alors là j'ai
mis suffisamment d'heures pour absorber
la totalité de la farine et je travaille
se lance en léger ou non et non ab ce
n'est pas vrai pour le moment non
nous avons simplement c'est un appareil
à crête
alors voyons là nous avons fait absorber
la farine par les eu et nous allons
maintenant voyez vous le beurre fondu
ici je vais ajouter un tout petit peu il
me semble que c'est un tout petit peu
léger vous savez comme ça la zone ajoute
un tout petit peu et puis je m'avait
fait j'avais ajouté
seul et dans lequel j'ai fait fondre le
beurre as voulait voir l'indicé que le
faire tourner il est chaud oui monsieur
n'a pas gagné borders étant donné le peu
de quantité par rapport à la pâte
il pourrait être froid n'ont parfois ils
pourraient être un peu plus tiers de
qu'il ne faut plus attendre quelques
minutes de plus enfin en réalité ça n'a
pas une très grande importance
voilà vous y que la quantité était en
selle aucune espèce d'importance cette
quantité là j'en ai mis peu parce qu'il
en faut peu il envoie juste assez pour
faire fondre le beurre bon ceci étant
terminée je m'en vais ajouter deux
ordres de la pièce de la bière alors là
de la vie en quantité suffisante
maintenant je vais vous pas une donnée
une précision extrême
si je faisais des crêpes sucrées
n'est ce pas à ce moment ci j'ajoute
avait le parfum c'est à dire le parfum
que j'aurai choisi
oui moi j'aime beaucoup l'europe par
exemple j'aime beaucoup laurent et le
rhum et puis une liqueur quelconque
anisé je mélange unique et anisé et
durant pour la proportion d'un tiers de
l'écart anisé pour de tir d'europe
ensuite voyez vous je m'en vais saler
légèrement ça de toute façon qu'elle
soit sucré ou salé vous savez de toute
façon de toute façon il faut saluer
aujourd'hui sont des crêpes salées salée
alors maintenant riez vous laisse aller
et je vais ajouter immédiatement la
bière alors la bière en quantité
suffisante pour faire une pâte
extrêmement légères alors là vous allez
voir jusqu'à quel point nous pouvons
arriver à faire une pâte et bien c'est à
dire presque de l'eau à ce point je ne
montrerai bien la consistance qu'elle a
en la faisant nous allons la passer au
chinois
de cette façon là oui parce que on ne
sait pas encore non il n'y en a pas mal
fait s'il y en avait nous jouons nous
aurions la sécurité en le passant aux
chinois par conséquent nous allons le
faire alors tout de suite tout de suite
4 il n'y avait pas le moindre mot je
vous assure c'est vraiment du luxe
on n'évolue pas dans leurs maîtres ont
levé
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci catherine voilà à l'oreille
aulas la pâte est encore trop épaisse
alors encore ajouté cela veut dire voilà
vous voulez nous faire reculer un peu
beaucoup oui alors je vais la faire
couler comme je suis un stand où elle
est gérée liquide
nous allons encore en ajouter
probablement d'ailleurs bon et bien que
l'on attendait les poêle à crêpes que
voici est il indispensable d'avoir
lesdites pour la crète pour une assiette
pour mettre les clubs lorsqu'elles
seront cuites mais ce changement avait
chopé poêle et faire les crêpes alors
vous remarquerez que je repars dans une
poêle sèche
n'est ce pas je n'ai absolument rien
dans la poêle vous pouvez dans le vé ça
sauf le fouet non je peux avoir besoin
l'assiette je vais avoir besoin de le
mettre sa complice et l'assiette la
voyez je chauffe les poils un tout petit
peu et je remarque que vous devez tait
absolument pas absolument pas non
ceci étant sans importance comment
débarrasse voilà je laisse chauffer
pouvez-vous avoir atterri un torchon net
et chaude
voilà autrement dit c'est la matière
grasse que vous avez mise dans
l'appareil qui suffit qu'il suffit de
largement détaché la crème de la
exactement et alors comme ça les crêpes
sont beaucoup plus légers
parce que eux n'ont pas cette matière
grasse supplémentaires ou à la poêle et
est pas tout à fait assez chaude là et
ici celle ci est chaude voire d'écoles
légèrement comme ceci va sans pouvoir la
prendre avec les doigts et à la
retourner
on ne peut pas les faire sauter ce pas
il est bien entendu
nous mêmes pas question d'essayer n'est
même pas question d'essayer on ne peut
pas les faire sauter par conséquent
n'essayez pas alors celle-ci déjà crise
voilà nous allons la mettre ici nous
servions tout à l'heure en continuer à
les faire comme ça très vite on va en
faire simplement 6 d'ailleurs six ou
huit n'ont pas vraiment faire beaucoup
la démonstration soit suffisante
bon alors nous renforcions sont celles
que l'on juge personne exactement et
qu'il n'ya pas benoît absolument
tellement dit vous nous donnez pas une
recette si je comprends bien on est là
c'est demain la façon de la façon de
faire est extrêmement importante à
l'envoyer vers des parcours en club sont
très très légère d'hubert de l'huile la
cuillerée d'huile reste absolument hors
d'elle oui parce que nous allons faire
avec ses crêpes des hors d'oeuvre au
chaud chez vous alors vous allez voir le
talent a ajouté de la bière dans
l'appareil que nous avons de façon le
faire encore plus légers valoir jusqu'à
quelle jusqu'à quel degré nous pourrions
arriver c'est à dire faire des clubs
d'une légèreté absolument sensationnel a
dit examiner trois quarts de la
bouteille c'est de l'eau c'est très très
liquides voyez vous c'est aussi les
petites que de l'eau vient avec son aile
en faire des coeurs encore plus légère
les oeufs entiers
bon c'est bien le don nous arrêter à
l'époque il y avait aussi raison toute
percée et là il ya un petit va très vite
et celui ci les autres qui vont beaucoup
plus lentement
alors je peux me guider comme ceux ci
était absolument seul serait parfumé
d'ores et déjà qu'elle serait légèrement
sucré également mais on l aurait
légèrement se fera pas ce qui n'a pas
été nécessaire et que légèrement allégé
voyez vous comme elle sont légères et
c'est peut-être commis en cinq clics à
6,7 je fais 1 800 ça suffira parce que
ça me pas 80 cette façon voilà c'est
terminé
n'en parlons plus excusez moi une toute
petite seconde
les chais ce thème occupé de celle ci
voilà ici aussi d'ailleurs non marchand
la magie et catherine là
nous allons faire tout de suite et
rapidement une sauce béchamel dites-moi
la quantité vous aviez là vous aviez
vous de bien faire chez soi chante ça va
paraître mardi vous pouvez émettre 2 e
tout petit peu de farine
beaucoup sont bien là en faire tout de
suite si vous voulez bien une petite
sauce béchamel très rapidement plusieurs
recettes
we use and honey 2 alors un peu de
beurre ici à fond et j'ai dû les qui
chauffe chauffe danser les quiches avait
pas y être
rendez vous est donné la farine merci
une cuillerée de farine comme ceux ci
voient là et que mais là je fais un roc
et roe qui va être vraiment vous oh oui
mais après il faut pas que ce serait ce
que ce soit en roubles en maintenant un
rouble en voilà ici nous allons saler le
lait légèrement est également le
muscadet voilà le ciel et voilà la
muscade suffit d'être de la muscade des
dents voilà alors le roux et si haut
niveau est assez roues il est cuit selon
le refroidit que vous refroidit c'est
souvent les foules refroidi enfants
qu'ils ne fassent pas de grumeaux
et puis l'a aussitôt je le mouille donc
aussi voilà
prenez des précautions après mois
diverses ça tout doucement avec
et voici ma sauce béchamel catherine
j'espère bien d'ailleurs je ne le jeu ne
le passerai pas je ne passerai pas c'est
toi je vais simplement toi tu chinois
pour cette fois-ci s'il y en a
voilà bien joué dans les circuits un
petit peu je vais préparer une petite
saison je n'ai mis que j'ai mis du sien
de la muscade catherine non alors ici je
vais prendre part dont deux ont offert
une petite liaison sans vie dans une
assiette creuse un jaune c'est le jaune
ils vont me servir pour l'horizon et
deux jours ceci ne me sert plus à rien
ceux ci n'ont voulu
voilà alors je passe les deux journées 6
2 dans une cuillerée de crème comme ceci
voilà je viens ici et dont 7 cuillerée
de crème et ses jaunes qui font la
liaison
je vais verser une partie rapidement de
la sauce béchamel qui va faire la
liaison que je vais reverser ici le dans
des sociétés à la présidence est
important se fait rapidement ça n'a
aucun risque de tournage de tourner à
condition que ce soit vite fait et sans
surtout laissez cuire les gens le
premier cours après une cuisson plus
reste presque plus depuis les c'est ça
bon eh bien maintenant catherine c'est
fini nous allons pouvoir parler de
choses très sérieuses c'est à dire de la
façon de faire c'est créer c'était
vraiment si c'était très peur la
première recette que je vais vous donner
va être une recette de clubs au jambon
avec cette béchamel commence vraiment me
dit tu crées peugeot je vois arriver une
le noma mais voici du jambon réalité
reste du jambon d'york et j'étais à dire
qu il serait de paris et ce serait très
bien
d'ailleurs bon et vous je m'en vais le
coupé lâché en quelque sorte pas du tout
pas du temps que vous le coup pied en
coty juliet en julienne exactement en
julienne cette juliette je la mets ici
dedans je vais ajouter un peu de fromage
râpé de fromage de gruyère pardon non
par ap mais couper de la même façon que
j'ai coupé alors s'il vient il viendra
tout à l'heure pour m'adapter
brice y voyez-vous je coupe comme ceci
dans un sens et puis je me le coupé dans
l'autre sens pardon c'est à dire à
julienne aussi géant les différencie ce
n'est pas le quai au fromage par
l'accueil au fromage
on peut dire crêpe au fromage qu'on a un
peu trop mal c'est là et puis là dedans
je m'en vais verser une partie de cette
sauce car elle va servir à plusieurs
sets je comprends bien oui non je vais
mélanger tout cela ensemble notre pécha
mail qui a été lié maintenant rejoint le
genre dont il fera alors naturellement
je ne vais pas ça l'est parce que le
fromage et un chalet est également le
jambon mais par contre je vais ajouter
un tout petit peu de cayenne mais en
très très peur
voilà et bien maintenant je vais pas en
plat à gratin en plaques fois au four
je vais mettre dessus un peu de peur que
voilà n'est ce pas avec un pinceau de
ces temps de ce verger des tomates
oui à des tomates alors maintenant il y
aura en plus du beurre et surtout de m
la prison et puis les crêpes voyons que
j'ai un petit peu de place les crêpes je
vais encore je crois que j'ai dit que
j'en avais carton de chacun là je crois
enfin ces deux étant jamais sûr de
retrouver ce qu'on a eu droit qu'à
quatre
je vais mettre une grande cuillère et
dans le choc comme ça vous vous en
sortirez pas si regardez allô allô le la
soupière
là on est plus qu'il n'en faut pardon
mais m quoi en faire j'ai pas qu on
vient là et je roule comme ceux ci et si
je comprends bien ça va aller au four
après avoir mis un peu de fond de sauce
de beurre et de fromage alors voyez vous
ici il me reste de la sauce pas beaucoup
mais suffisamment en forme on a fait des
crêpes on a fait un tout petit peu de
sauce part proposé d abord avoir besoin
d'un peu de beurre comme ceci je
récapitule voilà et des fromages gruyère
râpé
alors là après jour voilà nous allons
mettre ça au chaud pour le moment ici
bon eh bien nous allons prendre une
seconde recette pour cette seconde
recette voici une queue doma que nous
allons utiliser dans l'entente de la
moitié seulement qui sont à suffire
largement est bien avec le restant des
hommages effet une source à la voyez
vous je vais
escaloper comme ceux ci et le mettre
dans une petite un petit bol dans ma
casserole dans laquelle j'ai de la
béchamel
je vais la mettre chaussettes béchamel
autrement dit il faut pour cette raison
il vaut mieux en avoir est d'ores et
déjà mais je vais mettre de la sauce
américaine que j'ai fait avec le restant
du moment c'est à dire avec la carapace
or si je vous ai appris à l'a fait à
quatre alors c'est une sauce qui était
avec des échalotes flamber et puis on
ajoute le homard dedans on mouille avec
du vin blanc et d'aromates on laisse
cuire et on passe on obtient cette sauce
qui s'affaisse de la sauce américaine
alors la voici cette fois ça méricaine
nous allons répondre à peu près la
moitié pour mettre dans le sol picon de
homard
ça s'appelle un salpicon nous allons
également disposer les crêpes comme nous
avons fait tout à l'heure une deux trois
quatre
merci catherine nous allons les cours et
avec ce sale [ __ ] partiront il faut un
petit peu moins parce que oui c'est tout
de même beaucoup le riche n'est ce pas
et puis plus riches surtout c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une place à l'autre très bon
marché celui là est encore un peu plus
chez nous allons rouler les crêpes sur
elle même
l'heureux beurré oui on reverrait ce
plat que nous avons fait avec l'autre
très grassement
voilà les crêpes les unes sur les autres
non bien sûr n'hésite à côté des autres
la sauce dessus le restant de sauce va
aller dessus sur les crédits à part la
couleur évidemment la gauche si oui ce
serait différent l'a pas prononcée
6 6 6 2 et fromages la même façon non je
n'en ai plus besoin merci voici le
beurre que je met dessus et nous allons
faire gratiner tout de suite dans le
four alors le four est chaud dans le
haut et pas alors je vais donc louvre et
je vais mettre côte à côte ils se
battront n'ont d'ailleurs pas vous
laisser le four voilà et bien si vous
voulez catherine nous allons répéter
cette recette c'est à dire surtout la
recette des crêpes je voudrais surtout
insister car le reste n'a pas grande
importance mais celle des 7 à 9
parce qu'au fond nous avons le temps ont
pris comme prétexte de l'émission les
quêtes et nous avons fait des crêpes
pour pouvoir démontrer ensuite comment
les utiliser alors j'ai donc dit ne pas
peser la farine
ce maître de la farine au tour sera pas
un portage à puzzle par la pesée
l'anglais ben tu as une île au milieu
kas est suffisamment d'heures pour
absorber toute la famille ensuite faire
fondre dans du lait en gros morceau de
beurre c'est à dire pour un idiot pour 4
personnes il en faut 100 g lorsque ce
beurre fondu dans le lait mélangé les
beurs dans la pape
ensuite parfumé lorsqu'il s'agit de bord
de crêpes sucrées et mettre du sel et du
la muscade parce qu'il s'agit au
contraire de creps à gérer ces salles et
servant à un plat sel dans les deux cas
ensuite ajoutez du de la bière en
quantité suffisante passé suffisait
alors vraiment suffisante et trier il en
faut beaucoup
bon eh bien je crois catherine nous
pourrions si vous voulez faire une crème
ou deux pendant que ça gratis en fait ça
c'est une question et une précision car
c'est une habitude tout de même est ce
qu'on doit laisser la laisser reposer la
pâte qu'un jour vous l'avez non il
vaudrait mieux
oui car il vaudrait mieux c'est
extrêmement pertinents il vaudrait mieux
la laisser reposer enfin que l'on peut
très bien ne pas la laisser reposer nous
démontrer alors voyez vous la poêle
sèche absolument sèche très peu de pâte
à l'intérieur pas très chaud il fait
rien ça ira quand même leur laisser
cuire quelques secondes à retourner et
vous allez voir que lorsque la reprise a
remarqué qu'elle était fragile de talent
c'est parce qu évidemment j'arrêterai
c'était un peu frais elle prend du corps
et le poids du corps
non non mais non cheyrou qui me l'avait
fourni en me donnant la raison car au
fond c'était une espèce et c'était la
raison voyez vous on cuit alors on ne
peut pas je voulais dit les faire sauter
on doit aller tourner avec les mecs
parce que vous pensez que c'est une
grande joie des rennais bien écouter
catherine que je veux bien vocation
ah oui vous auriez fait sauter les
crêpes et bien voilà maintenant c'est
terminé la démonstration je crois aussi
loyaux cette crème est extrêmement fine
la voile et je l'espère on n'a rien
mangé personne qui sait bien qu'après si
vous voulez nous allons montrer les deux
plans qui sont maintenant gratiné nous
allons reprendre si vous voulez les
grands principes
est ce qu'il y à d'autres façons de
préparer comme vous dites de crêpes
order oui ce sont ceux que l'on peut
taper des hors d'oeuvre au chaud ça peut
s'appeler d'ailleurs des pancakes on
appelle ça souvent des pannes qui c'est
le mot d'ailleurs français de le pancake
par exemple à la place de
doma encore on peut mettre ce que l'on
veut on peut mettre par exemple des
langoustes il on peut mettre
naturellement des langoustes ou ou des
crevettes par exemple ce qui est
excellent à refaire le même principe de
source c'est à dire de sa mairie ken que
l'on fait toujours avec les carapaces et
on garde les morceaux nobles les
morceaux fin pour mettre dans la
garniture et puis aussi on peut avec une
béchamel que l'on transforme en une
journée c'est à dire en y ajoutant du
fromage et des gens d'affaires avec
beaucoup de joie des champignons oui oui
on peut faire des crêpes avec des
champignons à l'intérieur avec du du
gruyère simplement 100 m de jambon avec
du jambon avec des légumes comme des
fonds d'artichauts par exemple on peut
faire des quantités de variantes mais la
base est le départ et dans deux jours en
mer mais pas est toujours un tout petit
peu de sauce de façon à ce que ce soit
tout de même moelleux et que la clope ne
brûle pas au four voilà ce qu'il faut
chercher c'est d'avoir des quelques
voyous qui égratigne bien et qu'ils ne
brûlent pas mais je crois que je n'ai
plus rien vous avez convaincu
je crois qu'il nous reste à vous dire
bon appétit avec le jambon le fromage ou
bien les crevettes les langoustines ou
le home
merci raymond je vous en prie bonsoir
[Musique]